- All right!
Hey, palsies!
My name is Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help so much,
I'm making these videos called...
Guess what?
Today, I am gonna teach you
how to be a Helpster.
So, a Helpster
is a monster who helps,
so job one is...
be a monster.
So, how do you do that,
you might ask.
Well, um, let's see.
Oh, monsters love to smile,
so you gotta smile.
Like this.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Good!
Ok, let's see. What else?
Ooh! Ooh. Monsters can move
really fast. Like this.
And this.
And this!
Like that.
And Monsters love to dance.
Like this.
[music plays]
And last, but not least,
Monsters love to sing.
Like this.
♪ Boppity-bop-bop,
boo-dee-doh ♪
♪ I love to sing ♪
Yeah!
[audience applauding]
Oh, thank you.
That's very kind of you.
Congratulations!
You're a monster.
Now, job two
is to find a way to help.
And I have a few ideas.
You can put your toys away, or you can
put books back on the bookshelf,
or hang up your coat,
or put dirty clothes in the hamper,
or, uh, or you could help cheer
someone up by playing with them.
Or-or, if someone needs quiet time,
you can help by playing by yourself.
Ooh-ooh! Or, you can do
my favorite thing ever,
which is...
ask someone how you can help.
-[cell phone rings]
-Oh. Oh, excuse me just a moment. Uh...
Hello?
- Cody, it's Mr. Prim.
I am in need of your help.
- Ooh, well, of course, Mr. Prim.
Let me just say good-bye
to everybody first.
- Uh, good-bye?
Good-bye to whom?
Oh, well, you see, I'm making
these little videos right now,
and I just wanted to tell
everyone watching to make sure they help
the people and monsters around them,
'cause everyone loves a helping hand.
- Hmm. I believe
you just did tell them that.
- Oh, yeah! Ha!
See you next time, everybody!